[Applause]
[Music]
good offensive port work for Michael
Beasley a resounding rebound in its time
but it makes it easy that was closer
than I thought
game I'm sorry does a good job on the
glass and now has the block shot now
looking to get on the books Beasley on
the pull-up soft touch rattles around
drops through suspicious start for
beastly very good offensive rebounders
that pass from wall stolen by Beasley
mixed with a couple of nice steals he
kicks it out well he's mastered by the
Wizards and the next turn the turtle
divided into a Courtney Lee three
opponents three-point percentage wall
throws it away to Beasley this is third
turnover tonight you can't her running
the floor foul and good good strong
hands dealing with the contact chance
for a three-point play
he's got 12 now there's a shore right
knee plate of a niche first preseason
game
[Applause]
it comes hot away with Beasley
[Music]
so TV you should even practice it and
you should also practice other jump
balls you do know what's gonna happen
easily throw someone down left handed
he's here by the way
former Kings teammates to job as well so
a chance for a three-point play pirate
basketball is a game of improvisation
these the six nine improvising that
sound mesmerizing off the glass that's
it again PCEHR playing with three fouls
these jumpers garrix
he played last night as did Ron Baker
for the Knicks Westchester Knicks in the
Julie shot blocked by basil Evers 113
but only give up 103 feet average is 105
there's loose pins flips it up and in
with the off hand and got foul a chance
for a three-point play from Michael B's
and he's a southpaw wheeling and dealing
soaring dicksterity jack fires it across
diseases back up top part away
Hardaway pull-up jumper that's good but
it's off to a hips and starring 6 of 8
from the field that's two Americas
three ball with duping this time the
former self defects inside blocked by
Beasley excellent recovery
this Jonathan Simmons the former spur
drives right at Emily
two cities these Lee has these billions
create his own shot though some ass
today
he likes to write south pass out sloppy
pass there we gets it back the lever
lobs it up and peasley with one hand
throws it down a nerd revs his 11th
rebound Beasley running the floor back
to McDermott
[Music]
which CAC aggressive defense on my whip
easily gets away from it switches to the
right-hand suite play for Michael
Beasley take a look at these these have
been personal Dexter's superthin
whooping with the right hand
nine to shoot they want to get to
Beasley just give him some room against
levert Beasley little body from Luverne
Beasley off-balance smooth visiting he's
a highly skilled officer is he sure edge
seven the shooter
[Music]
[Applause]
picked up by Beasley Drive spins in the
truth the black of course was in the
trade form that one's got to stay on his
feet
Anthony up and under
[Applause]
it's a good block is a beautiful drop
step move now that looked like a good
rejection Beasley gets it back for two
by Brad Stevens it offensive rebounds
but a nice spurt by the Knicks as they
have pulled to within four here's
Beasley this slams it down I'm selfish
passion received from the mix now that
one thing since Tim Hardaway went up my
speed it's a sport the system Frank
militina in the game finds Beasley
Beasley good extra pass to Quinn and
that's beautiful to work there or
Zynga's first contact there Beasley tips
it to himself brought a fight you know
Lee Beesley gets inside right-handed and
the foul switched hands or switch the
ball to his right and now a chance for a
three-point play
it's time Beasley defiant hanging in the
air dexterity with the right hand
because they remind me of the teams I
played with right yeah the way they play
the professionalism on the court the
Latina fakes it since I throws it down
species Beasley spins inside lamp is
good at a foul
Michael Beasley with a chance for the
three-point play
Davis releases down the other end
Beasley cut hustle tries to save it he
does Michael Beasley will the hustle
play nil akina's sees some opening drive
Dallas scoop layup this girl turns back
the other way traveling the Knicks by
six as wall was paddled up another
Washington turnover Neely kena
takes it all the way lays it in with the
left hands who clever slick move Frank
here's wall five score top block Beasley
and regained by the Wizards and a foul
by McDermott as Gortat hits the floor
surprises was his ability to block shots
in 69 right down this way hex here's
some tears about this he crowd had the
foul and then come to his left right
inside so he's going to overwhelm
[Music]
squeeze the two four out there he could
get doubled he's way over the head and
look at the creativity just over a
minute remaining third quarter he's led
by six at the half
off the steal here comes Beasley
three-on-one Beasley sets up leave who
lays it in
pulling the next to it into Hotel the
ditch by to chef Marquis at three
peasley puts up the three thousand
Beasley with the left and he's happy
taxes only wailed scoring-wise
it's a little delusional a bit
there's no ABBA blocked from behind by
Beasley Norton Crawford thought he was
fouled and now he's we have the field
slams it home well night for for Beasley
court permitted Mansoor this stuff was
hurt hustling but in vain nila kena gets
it throws it out too late he drives back
to
nasty stuff I Beasley in the last
several we mention competition right
Beasley kicks it out to Baker's bake her
rotten open catch the three
pilgrim Harrison shut off nicely by
milky good G Vitamix it's the scenario
blocked by be slinging pile Quinn
distinguishes him for her in Houston
tenacious d nice feed inside and Cantor
the finish Michael Beasley with a good
luck coaches to me he's the harvest soul
of his team Beasley goes inside all
beautiful adjustment from Beasley
Durant's still arguing about the pom
there's Burke bottled up by yogic
Beasley tails are three example awning
off putting some shots now down to 33
percent shooting Beasley on the stuff on
a nice feed from Villa Caitlin pitch and
their beneficiaries Beasley they think
he has a chance to be special Beasley on
the drive gets inside layups good and a
foul
bullseye theatres watch this
right-hand-drive
completes it also to write in write on
and off the court and he's an energizer
for the Knicks perhaps one of their
better defenders along with Thomas
nice pass Jack to Hardaway 20 years ago
Beasley jumpers hits good as the shot
clock expires he's got 21
yeah 36 percent three ball points in the
paint philippics
it again what a year he's had here's
Beasley and the foul for Michael Beasley
will head to the free-throw line
ugh shot he's the culprit right here
getting up off his feet easily able to
beat him to do well hornacek after he
said that as Beasley pokes it away
Beasley with the steel comes down the
other way Turner in pursuit he's leave
the steal and the finish six
wrapped his fourth in the league in
scoring here is Beasley from three
here's part just Adamas Beaubourg ashley
canter with his eighth rebound in this
season Heisman
[Applause]
look at Spivak where's my heart away
[Applause]
doping Beasley the beneficiary may be a
doctor to the Gans of the niche
[Applause]
under the grooming tonight mid-range
jumper it's time to oldest play in
basketball the pick-and-roll working to
perfection
[Applause]
cabinets are up seven these lease
pinstripes and fishes boy it's just you
make shots that you don't think the
angle or were on the road shooting
Hornets Easley gets inside and a foul
and mix get a chance for three-point
play discombobulated on that time those
words are too bizarre reactions
defensively
Beasley's throws a towel on the right
hand I'm sure they had moment of silence
throughout the lead of all the games
tonight Beasley throws it down and a
foul lethargic now omnipotent f his
third dunk and the last 3 min I try to
throw some BP in the locker room now but
much shorter a little sore Beasley
connects and will head to the free-throw
line
[Applause]
as in mesmerizing fresh air with the
junk nice short eyes
Beasley gets past George Hill layout
Kyle Quinn had the rebound but lost it
makes it miss some laps all peasley mix
up the area form puts it home usually
Thomas in there stuffing Beasley has
Thomas mister that's it although not an
intimidating team they all averaged
three blocks again this 28 Austin Dillon
tip put it Nantz gets the rebound Jeff
Green back to James drives right at
these elite layup blocked to help
defense there from Oh quick it was down
by three rejection is blue gives the
pass - Wow nice job but beads look not
only making a clean block that's
floating away from boy it's pretty when
you're rootin for him it's maddening
when you're not disputing calls doesn't
get another look at that assists from
Beasley - heart away from their home Jim
Posey right here because they trailed by
Rock the Rama plasma catches it just one
jab faking boy he elevated once he cut
into the paint put the ball in his right
hand
flushed nice job with a record of 13 and
9 negra Beasley thought about it
three-point chance for Beasley he's
being able to score this is a god that
is historically as he left hander throws
it up with his right hand that time
there's one foot nine from downtown
against the Lakers well make the early
pass easy pass through weak side
continuing to encourage his guys a good
move by Michael Beasley got good shots
[Music]
Beasley driving and he is a terrific
scorer former number two overall pick
Beasley pulls up they work it around
back up the ball Beasley gets it back
one second
great ball movement
[Applause]
Beasley making plays with one another
this is stuff you practice on dribble
penetration make the extra pass
I'd open three just you look at it
twenty-one attempted threes in just one
free-throw at some point you got to find
a way to get to the cuff and put
pressure on this Lake of defense will
add a double-double in his return for 38
kcp it's chased down by B's all good cop
at Casey fooled and Beasley finds it
Stephenson from his left hand to his
right